JEREMY WALKER: Hi all.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have a great show today.
We're going to talk to 9x9 TV.
So let's get started.
We have William Sheu,
VP of Engineering.
I'm Jimmy Walker.
We have special guests from
New York, Ikai Lan.
IKAI LAN: I am a very
special guest.
No, I'm visiting headquarters
this week.
JEREMY WALKER: Visiting
headquarters.
THOMAS DELL: He's
very special.
JEREMY WALKER: And then
we have Thomas
Dell, who's a developer.
So let's get started.
We're going to go and talk
about the company first.
And then we'll dive into
some demos, and
we'll talk tech stuff.
So what is 9x9 TV?
WILLIAM SHEU: All
right, 9x9 TV.
9x9 TV is a Silicon
Valley company.
We are headquartered
in Santa Clara.
And then we have international
office in Taipei and Beijing.
We are funded by venture
capital, and also there are
some corporate investor.
And so, we are doing
good so far.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, so what is
the goal behind 9x9 TV?
WILLIAM SHEU: Essentially, the
goal is that we try to create
a next-generation platform to
allow the user to enjoy the
internet video on their
choice of screen.
For example, the screen can
be a phone, a tablet,
computer, or TV.
But the thing is that the word
"enjoy" is a big word.
You know people have different
level of the
fitting for the enjoy.
So how exactly people enjoy
watching internet
video is big deal.
So, we identify a true problem,
we try to solve.
The first problem is what to
watch, since there are
millions and billions of
video in the internet.
For example, I think YouTube
has maybe like one hour of
video uploaded per second.
That's huge, all right?
So then people simply will
get lost in this massive
amount of the video.
So the first problem
is what to watch.
The second is how--
how to watch it.
So people have this intention
to watch on tablet, on a
phone, and on TV.
And each device have its
own special feature.
So 9x9 tried to come out
different user interface
design, and to provide different
user experience
which will allow the user to
enjoy watching internet video
on those devices to the most.
JEREMY WALKER: So very much
video discovery, and finding
what you'd want to watch.
WILLIAM SHEU: Exactly
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So tell me about the name 9x9.
Where did that come about?
WILLIAM SHEU: OK.
Yeah, this is interesting.
It's actually not a
random pick name.
There's actually an interesting
story behind this.
So this actually will come
back to our initial
design of the UI.
Because as you can understand,
that our idea is that to try
to provide a user what
to watch the best.
So we have this philosophy
of less is more.
Less complexity is simplicity.
So if a less resource
[INAUDIBLE], people will
become more happy because
there's a small--
less hassle to deal with.
So based on this philosophy,
our UI designs
are come out of design.
And the design is a grip with
nine row by nine column.
And so, and we look at the UI
design and say, oh, why don't
we call the company 9x9?
And so that's [INAUDIBLE].
Everybody is now happy.
Oh, that's the name of
the company, 9x9.
There, we have the name.
Here we go.
9x9 TV here in the
Google Campus.
JEREMY WALKER: Awesome.
WILLIAM SHEU: This--
I'm not making up this story.
This is true.
I think Thomas can--
JEREMY WALKER: Attest to it.
WILLIAM SHEU: --certify
this is accurate.
THOMAS DELL: It kind of locks us
into a user interface which
we're, you can see, that it's
not going to [INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: So what was your code
before you officially
named the company?
WILLIAM SHEU: Well, we have
a few code name before.
But yeah, I don't want
to talk about that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEREMY WALKER: So I was messing
around with your app,
and I noticed something that was
called Day Parting which
you guys do.
And I don't think a lot of
people know what that is.
Actually, I didn't know what
it was till I looked it up.
But can you tell us what Day
Parting is, because I think
that's kind of important
for your app.
It's kind of a neat feature.
WILLIAM SHEU: Absolutely,
absolutely.
As you know that, we try to
provide the most relevant
video for people to watch, OK?
And we try to think about, and
try to exam people's watching
behavior on the TV.
And we notice that people
actually want to watch certain
video at a certain
time of the day.
For example, when you wake up
in the morning, you have the
expectation to watch
morning news.
And then, after the day, you
may want to watch something
more relaxing, OK?
And in the night, you want
to watch something--
you don't want people
to know about it.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM SHEU: So in the sense
that we try to understand
people's watching behavior, and
then we come out this idea
of Day Parting Essentially, we
tried to divide the video into
different categories, and assign
a category to different
time of the day.
And we then allocate those video
into our user interface
design, so that when you visit
our website or use tablet, or,
later on, use Google TV, then
you will watch certain video
at that time.
Again, this is a fundamental
philosophy of less is more.
We don't give you more video.
We'll give you less video, and
you actually will enjoy more.
That's the whole idea
behind this.
And then, we also spent a lot of
time doing this, more than
just select video randomly.
We have algorithms which try to
figure out a lot of video,
a lot of channel.
And then, the curator, which
is provides human touch.
Then we'll select--
hand-pick from those
automatically filtered video
or channel, then compose
the best list of
video for you to watch.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So you're kind of curating at
two levels-- an algorithm
level and a user level.
WILLIAM SHEU: Absolutely.
We believe that's the
best combination.
Another company doing this
by algorithm only.
And we believe that without
human touch, the video won't
have its own style, won't have
its taste that [INAUDIBLE] to
particular group of people.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, let's stop talking and
let's start demoing, because I
think I always like to see what
we're talking about just
to get an idea of-- because I'm
a visual person-- just to
get an idea of what's going on.
So let's--
I think we're starting with the
tablet, and then we'll go
to Google TV, so.
THOMAS DELL: This is
our tablet app.
Turn on the tablet.
Is that visible on the screen?
OK.
Now we'll just start it.
And this is actually accessing
a YouTube account.
And so these subscriptions that
we see are actually kept
by YouTube.
And we can either handle our own
subscriptions, or YouTube
can handle it.
You can use your YouTube
subscriptions.
Either way is.
OK, so what we have here is
a Day Part at the top.
And this is a channel selected
for this particular time of
day, and based on your other
usage behaviors.
And on the right, the first
channel, when this opens up,
this is what we call
a virtual channel.
And this is a mix of content
from all of these channels.
But if we want to, we can enter
one of the channels
specifically.
And I'm going to go to
our subscriptions.
And so this on the right
are episodes
from all these channels.
And we'll pick the Google Talks
since we're at Google.
JEREMY WALKER: Nice.
THOMAS DELL: Now that I've
selected this, these are all
episodes from one channel,
from Google Talks.
And, let's play one.
OK, so at the bottom
here are the other
episodes in this channel.
We can subscribe to this channel
or unsubscribe to it.
If we don't want to watch
this episode, we can--
I'm doing this from a funny
angle-- we flip to the next
episode by going
left to right.
We could also flip by going
up and down to different
channels, but we're not
going to do that.
We can move around inside of an
episode by just adjusting
this or pausing.
One of the features that I can't
show you because of the
set up in here is we can take
whatever's showing on this,
and we can throw it onto a
television by clicking on
Watch on TV.
So this shows us actually that
there is a Google TV available
in the room.
Unfortunately, we don't
have enough cameras
to show it to you.
But if I clicked on this button,
this video would start
playing on the television
over there.
And this allows you in your
living room to pick what you
want to see on the tablet, and
then broadcast it on-- or,
just throw it out to
the television.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And this is available--
the tablet one is the available
now in Google Play?
THOMAS DELL: Yes, this is
currently in Google Play, yes.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, let's have a look at
the Google TV version.
This is pretty neat. too.
And yeah, we apologize to
the users out there.
We didn't have the setup to
let them fling it on.
But anyway, you can fling
your video onto
this application here.
And, do you want to walk
through, William?
WILLIAM SHEU: Sure.
Jeremy allow me to
maybe reclick a
commercial message here.
So 9x9 TV is now in the Google
Play, so you're welcome to
download it.
And I'd like to use one quote
from a TechCrunch article
about 9x9 TV.
This is cool.
"If you are one of those people
with an Android device,
and cannot figure out what type
of video to watch, please
download from Google Play store
and then try it out." So
this is some--
we consider as a compliment
from TechCrunch.
So I think that's--
hopefully now you can download
it and give it a try.
OK, now I'm going to do to show
you the Google TV version
of the same concept.
This version is still under
developing, and should be
released in the next
few weeks.
So this version has the same
idea in terms of Day Parting.
So as you can see
on the screen,
there's a morning show.
And the first position
in the grid of the
3x3 grid is All Updates.
So essentially, all the new apps
will be list in this All
Updates channel.
We call this kind of channel
virtual channel.
And the rest of the channel
is the real channel.
So if we can flip through the
channel, and then you pick any
channel to watch.
So this is the morning show.
And similar to the tablet
version, we also have On
Previously.
So the On Previously with
the morning news, OK?
So with a remote control, you
can simply use the left and
right, up and down to navigate,
to reposition, and
to choose any channel
to watch.
So we can do that by simply
click right, and right.
And then go to this,
Following page.
Because I've assigned this
to this app previously.
And so, we have this Following
page from my own subscription.
So now we can play one video
from this All Updates.
OK, we can play one
video here.
JEREMY WALKER: This will go
into all your updates.
So does the left and-- or, left
and right to the screen,
those go to different
Day Parting things?
WILLIAM SHEU: Yes, exactly.
The Day Parting we use, the
channel we consider as a
default channel.
So in addition to the default
channel for everybody, we
actually allow the user to
import the channel from your
own subscription form YouTube,
or subscription from 9x9 TV
JEREMY WALKER: So you have
Following, you have your own
subscriptions, and
you have the Day
Parting, so you can kind--
WILLIAM SHEU: Exactly,
exactly.
JEREMY WALKER: --of go with
whichever one best fits.
WILLIAM SHEU: In the future,
we actually will assign
different channels from
your subscriptions
into the Day Parting.
For example, your subscription,
you have CNN news.
And then we will assign
CNN news to the
morning news section.
Maybe you have some other, more
interesting channel you
like watch in the night,
or you are prone to
watch in the night.
Then we were assign those
channel into the Primetime or
[INAUDIBLE] session of
the Day Parting.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
WILLIAM SHEU: So, yeah, this
is the Google TV demo.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, well,
now Ikai, I know you're
waiting to get into
the details.
So let's get into some
of those questions.
IKAI LAN: Absolutely.
So Tom, first off, I don't think
we fully introduced what
you do for 9x9.
THOMAS DELL: I wrote this app.
I wrote our web app, also, and
part of the back-end--
the part dealing with
the synchronization.
IKAI LAN: So that's a web app,
that's an Android app, and a
Google TV app, which are same
thing, if I'm not mistaken--
THOMAS DELL: Yeah, yeah.
IKAI LAN: --as well
as well as a--
THOMAS DELL: Yeah, we actually
have one app that determines
what it's running on, and
then acts accordingly.
IKAI LAN: So what technology
stacks did you use to build
this product on top of?
THOMAS DELL: Well, on the web,
we used jQuery But actually,
on Android, we don't use
very many stacks.
We use we use the
APIs directly.
And I don't even use
fragments for this.
So I'm kind of anti-platform
when it comes to dealing with
mobile apps.
But it's just like if it's
not in the API, I--
IKAI LAN: Right.
Did you look into any using
jQuery for the web front-end?
I mean, did you look into
using any front-end
frameworks?
And if not, if didn't
choose any, why not?
THOMAS DELL: Well, we used
some libraries with the
front-- with the
web front-end.
But, are you referring to mobile
front-end frameworks?
IKAI LAN: I'm referring to kind
of like the full stack
frameworks, like-- not
necessarily full stack, but
more MVP or MVC frameworks,
like Angler, JS or--
Backbone's not really a
framework, but some of these
are the options out there.
THOMAS DELL: I think frameworks
lock you into
certain ways of thinking.
And if I can't do with--
there better be a really
compelling advantage to using
a framework.
And I think jQuery is an example
of a framework that
makes the development much, much
easier, like by an order
of magnitude, probably.
But unless I get that kind of a
gain, or if I don't need to
use a specific framework,
I'm not going to.
Because it just makes it harder
to back it out and
change something, or to do
something unanticipated.
IKAI LAN: What did you enjoy
most about building this
application?
THOMAS DELL: For a mobile app,
it's actually very nice to be
able to hold what you're doing,
and have it show up on
the TV, as well.
Making things that run
on television is
inherently neat, I think.
IKAI LAN: So was there a moment
when it was on a Google
TV, and you were kind of blown
away that you were able to put
this up there?
THOMAS DELL: Well, I think
it moves a little
bit slower than that.
You don't suddenly have
something that's on Google TV.
So there's no blown
away moment.
But it's very pleasing to have
what you're doing on your
television, and almost
far more than
almost any other platform.
The mobile device
comes second.
The web is not nearly
so exciting
when it comes to that.
IKAI LAN: So did you have any
challenges when you were
building this application?
THOMAS DELL: Our biggest
challenge is actually with
user interfaces, because there
are some complex concepts here
with channels, groups of
channels, episodes.
And it's very difficult to
convey to the user what
they're actually doing.
And it's very hard for them to
realize, oh, I'm looking at
this, and this is the type of
data that I'm looking at, or
the type of content that
I'm looking at.
And it's very easy
to get it wrong.
And a lot of other applications
do get it wrong.
And so it's--
IKAI LAN: Did you find that--
is there a process you guys
have in place for
validating a UI?
Like, you go through a couple of
iterations, maybe somebody
of these guys look at and say,
whoa, I have no idea
what's going on.
THOMAS DELL: Yeah.
And we try to bring in
outsiders, people who aren't
tainted by having used it
before, and have them try it,
find out what they're confused
about, and then iterate
through that, as well.
IKAI LAN: In building this
application, what's burning on
your backlog that you
just want to do?
At least from a technical
standpoint, not from a product
or future standpoint.
THOMAS DELL: From a technical
standpoint, we still have some
issues with--
just some of APIs make it
difficult to do some of the
things we want to do.
Because a lot of the Google APIs
our fine if you're doing
what they expect you to do.
But if you go off the script,
if you want to do something
that the authors of the API
didn't expect you to do, often
it becomes quite difficult.
And some of the other APIs, just
outside of this app, like
the new HTTP--
the web view API, for
instance, has
had some issues with--
there's many, many methods.
And yet, there's no
method to view the
content of the web API.
So it's like something
fundamentally basic is missing
because whoever designed the
API wouldn't necessarily be
thinking in that direction.
And we run into this a little
bit here with us wanting to
display things on the screen
in certain ways.
And that's difficult
with this API.
But it's a little harder
to explain then.
WILLIAM SHEU: There's one thing
that I'd like to add.
You can see that we try to
provide the best user
experience possible.
So if frequently we
push to the limit.
We are on the cutting edge,
or a bleeding edge.
So constantly, I push Tom to--
can you do this, can
you do that?
If it doesn't work, or if this
API doesn't do what we want,
can we work around with it?
So we frequently in
this [INAUDIBLE]
kind of push into limit so that
user can get what they
wanted best.
So that's [INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: So, I have a more
general question for both you
guys, then, which is, if you
could go back to when you guys
first started building
this, what advice
would you give yourself?
One thing.
If you could take
one thing back.
THOMAS DELL: I don't even know
how to answer that question.
IKAI LAN: Probably should
have warned you
about that one, right?
THOMAS DELL: We actually
originally started building
apps using something
called XBMC.
I don't know if you've
heard of it.
IKAI LAN: I'm familiar
with XBMC.
THOMAS DELL: And so XBMC wasn't
really up to making
apps inside it, so I modified
the internals of XBMC to make
it so that we could
build apps.
But still, XBMC is not a stable
enough platform to do
what we want.
And actually, to Android's
credit, Android is plenty
stable for this kind of thing.
And this is far more stable than
our XBMC app ever was.
IKAI LAN: So I guess what you
would say to yourself is,
don't even bother.
Just start with Android.
THOMAS DELL: I probably
would say, let's not
even look at the XBMC.
I like XBMC a lot.
And XBMC does what it's
designed to do.
But we were trying to twist it
into something that it wasn't
designed to do.
WILLIAM SHEU: Yeah, I can try
to answer that question.
The [INAUDIBLE] in that will
be typical answer.
Because our [INAUDIBLE], the
audience keeps changing, and
we have a partner, they
have certain request.
So the dilemma is always that
how much our visibility is.
Frequently, our visibility may
be one month, three months,
very short.
But our schedule
is very tight.
So we kind of juggle it around
between the delivery and then
compare it to good planning,
or even a good design.
But the goal is that we
try to come out with
the best code possible.
And then we can deliver the
product in time so that our
partner can use it for the pilot
for the demo, and our BD
guy can also use it to pursue
our audience outside.
So that's kind of
typical answer.
But it's very true here,
particularly while using
something also very new.
So yeah, that's it--
something I'd like to
share with you.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
IKAI LAN: That's all
interesting stuff.
Is there anything else
you'd like to share
with us on the show?
With the viewers, perhaps?
WILLIAM SHEU: Or you can
compliment or complain or--
THOMAS DELL: Yeah, the API--
actually, the YouTube bit.
We used several APIs in this.
We used the YouTube
Player API.
And we use a OAuth API to login,
and get access to your
subscriptions.
And we also use the
YouTube Data API.
And actually, the combination
of those is pretty good.
And the YouTube Player
API is new, but
actually, it's pretty solid.
I still wish we could do certain
things, like we want
to have title cards which
take over the screen.
And some of the aspects of this
API interfere with what
we want to try and do.
And I hope that you guys
are willing to--
actually, the biggest problem
is with the YouTube--
I mean, with the OAuth API.
And that is, someone with
YouTube subscriptions is
forced to actually create a
YouTube channel in order for
us to access those YouTube
subscriptions.
And this doesn't make much
sense at all to the user.
It's kind of absurd that
you have to do this.
And that's something I really
wish would be fixed.
JEREMY WALKER: We're
looking into that.
But for the audience out there,
what he's saying is,
basically, you can create a
Google account, but then you
have to go through an extra
accepting thing terms to
create a channel, and then so
you guys can do stuff with.
THOMAS DELL: Because you can
subscribe to things, and it's
still not accessible.
And it tells the user, I think
the message is, this is not
linked to YouTube.
Which is, well, they're
using it on YouTube.
Of course it's linked.
JEREMY WALKER: We definitely
know about that, and we're
looking into it, so.
THOMAS DELL: There's a lot
of confusion on the
web about this, so.
IKAI LAN: But really confusing,
both to the users
and our developers.
So it's one of these things
where we look at it and we
think, well, developers, we
definitely don't want to be
confusing developers.
But users, for sure, and when
I started using the YouTube
API, that was the first
thing I ran into.
Also, on not my main account.
I didn't run into this
for a long time.
And then I created a new test
account, and I was like, why
am I getting this error?
THOMAS DELL: Yeah,
this is crazy.
IKAI LAN: Again, for anyone
that's watching who's anyone
who's thinking about building
YouTube, the first thing you
want to do have your users
create a channel because then
you won't get this
error message.
And we're looking at things we
can do to streamline this a
little bit more.
But thank you for that.
That's very, very useful
information for developers.
Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Well, let's
go to the questions.
We only have one, and I
think may be for you.
IKAI LAN: OK.
JEREMY WALKER: Is developer
relations hiring?
IKAI LAN: Is this--
did you set this up?
I feel like this is something
Jeremy puts into--
who's it by?
JEREMY WALKER: It was
by Jeremy Walker.
IKAI LAN: Jeremy Walker.
Wow, what a coincidence.
There's someone out there with
the same name as you.
The answer is, yes,
we are hiring.
We're hiring in multiple sites
across the world, mainly in
Mountain View.
But we also have developer
relations positions open in
New York City.
I believe we have some
in our London office.
Just definitely go to
developers.google.com/--
I think it's either "jobs" or
"careers." I think it's
"jobs."
JEREMY WALKER: "Jobs."
IKAI LAN: Right.
And you'll see a list
of our openings.
And do join us.
We get to do fun stuff.
The most fun of all is
interacting with developers,
which it's a must have if you
want to work for this group.
And sometimes it's a little
tough, but for the most part,
I love my job.
And Jeremy, you do, too.
JEREMY WALKER: Same here.
Well, thanks to our guests for
coming on and talking a little
bit about your app here,
technical details.
And I think that's
all we got today.
WILLIAM SHEU: OK, thank you.
Glad to be here.
IKAI LAN: Thank you
guys very much.
WILLIAM SHEU: Bye.